good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 29
[Music]
Keter special containment procedures SCP
29 to be incarcerated in a class 5
containment cell she is to be allowed
access to nothing of a physical nature
her containment cell is to be placed
behind a triple air lock to avoid her
escape as of incident
29:34 a SCP 29 to be fent as she does
not appear to need sustenance to survive
there are to be three guards on duty at
all times on her cell and two guards on
monitor duty floodlights have been
installed in the walls of the
containment chamber and are to be on at
all times once a month the chamber is to
be cleaned and checked for defense under
absolutely no circumstances are any men
to encounter a CP 29 in any manner any
males who do encounter SCP 29 or to be
held under class 3 detention for
interviewing before termination as CP 29
has requested a bed a blanket books and
clothes all denied this is ridiculous
the girl can't even have clothes we're
not animals
let her cover herself dr. Erica boudin
dr. boudin you are granted permission to
deliver clothes to SCP 29 dr. light
as of incident 2953 be anyone who has
potential access to SCP 29 to first
watch surveillance tape 29 Bodeen as a
reminder of threats involved when
working with SCP items and a-c-p 29 in
particular description SCP 29 to be a
pubescent female of Asiatic
Indian descent she appears to suffer
from alopecia universalis over 80% of
her pigmentation is true black while the
rest of her skin has a complete lack of
melanin to the point of albinism her
eyes are also at dark black in color SCP
29 has severe homicidal tendencies and
has displayed a remarkable ability to
use any item as a weapon however she has
a severe compulsion against shedding
blood preferring instead to strangle her
victims scp-2932 the average human SCP
29 has also displayed extensive
resistance to damage of all forms both
of these extra human abilities are
greatly hampered in the presences of
bright or direct light natural or
artificial in addition any males who
come within the presence of SCP 29 and
by her current perception find
themselves pliant to her will
such males become willing to kill or
even die for SCP 29 29 refers to herself
as which roughly translates to donger of
Darkness daughter of shadows or daughter
at night
interviews with SCP 29 to conduct due to
SCP 29 m / to speak with her over her
years of captivity the black patches on
her skin have increased in size SCP 29
was first brought to the foundation's
attention by an agent working in rural
India
an attempt on his life led him to a
small cult of men who claimed to be thug
e's in service to the daughter several
weeks of investigation proved that they
believed the world to be in the last
years of Kali Yuga and that by
sacrificing 1 million lives - the
daughter of darkness they could raise
their goddess and end the world they
also believed that only sacrifices
performed through strangulation added to
this tally events led the agent to their
mountain fortress where he discovered a
sea p29 after the loss of said agent
which ended in our acquisition of SCP 29
seven years after capture SCP 29 began
showing anomalous growth in her black
pigmentation when questioned about it
she claimed her followers were on the
move once more investigation led us to a
concentration of so-called
Huggies that had escaped our initial for
it after discovering that all her
followers were there for one of their
holy days a tactical air strike was
called in when the first bomb dropped as
CP 29 awoke from slumber screaming at
the top of her lungs as CP 29 continued
to scream for the next four hours
ranting and raving that we were killing
her people since said event the growth
of black pigmentation has stopped
completely also since said event SCP 29
to escape SCP 28:20 has been proposed as
a possible method of neutralization
should the situation worsen
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening and
you were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to all the time gaming Zach Geller
James Saba Katherine Jews Jax Merrick
Pablo ice 917 Burlington the cat
Kareem a la shmoop Justin de Pury kuma
Riley Shawn Murphy
Traver W peg white crew Nicholas James
boo Jack Bryson Billy my archive curator
neck tie verbal Alex Gil Dre rook the
Android Jacob Ganim PT quartz 5 6 3 and
tree hero if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos and some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Vulcan thank you
[Music]
you